Oh
hi good afternoon I'm Emily Underwood
science magazine today were doing a
Google hangout on the new diagram the
new diagnostic Statistical Manual of
Mental Disorders and with me today are
Frank Farley William Eaton and Alan
Francis we'll be taking questions
throughout the hour I hope you'll be
submitting them frantically it's gonna
be a great lively chat um let's get
going so our first question that I'd
like to start out with it comes from
Bianca and her question is why is the
dsm-5 ever useful and why has it lived
outlived its usefulness now if that's
the case I'd like you to brought guests
to take that question in turn um bill
can you can you get us started on that
question but she's not talking about
dsm-5 she's probably talking about the
DSM in GEMA
so um well one of the things that DSM
has led us do I'm an epidemiologist is
sorry my computer is so in 1994 I think
about then the The Economist came up
with a study called the global burden of
disease and that basically provided an
algebra to quantify the importance of
diseases by combining data on morbidity
with data on mortality it was the first
time that had happened and morbidity and
mortality somewhat morbidity is the
illnesses that occur regardless of
whether they're fail and mortality is
the illness is late it related to death
and as soon as they did that and they
they used epidemiologic data about
diagnosis and clinical vignettes about
diagnosis and that cranked the metal
disorders and the neuropsychiatric
emissions to the top of the chart in
terms of importance in
the in the developed world
neuropsychiatric conditions are the
leading cause of disability adjusted
life years and they will soon be the
leading cause of disability adjusted
life years throughout the world after
the lower-income countries go through
the epidemiologic transitions so that's
an important benefit to the DSM I think
and it would never have been possible if
the DSM had not allowed reliable
classification not necessarily valid but
reliable and that happened in 1980 well
you know my feeling would be that it was
more helpful than the way the world was
prior to DSM but I think it's really
played out it's string I think the
negatives now outweigh the positives I
know that Allen who is who has been
brilliant at dissecting the dsm-5 and
finding where all the product where are
all the bodies lie so to speak I would
still keep it but fix it and my feeling
would be it's it's beyond fixing and I
think that you know there won't be a DSM
6 and I think it's time now to really
rethink the whole concept of diagnosis
to break it out of the sort of
biomedical model and include as a whole
sort of bio psychosocial cultural model
and move on looking to the future so I
really feel that the DSM has has run out
of juice and really needs we need fresh
thinking on diagnosis next questions
Alan show us what are the bodies okay
well I think the issue is this
psychiatry is neither good nor bad the
DSM is neither good nor bad it's good
absolutely wonderful used well it can be
horribly harmful used badly I think once
the words are written they take on a
life of their own and the drug companies
have such tremendous marketing power
they've shanghaied the DSM and they
succeeded in convincing people that the
problems of everyday life are really
mental disorders due to a chemical
imbalance treatable by a pill so we have
a remarkable degree of diagnostic
inflation a quarter of the population
now qualifies for a mental disorder one
in five people is taking a psychiatric
medicine this is out of hand it has to
be controlled dsm-5 will make all of
this much worse turning diagnostic
inflation into hyperinflation
however with all of these problems the
DSM is enormous ly useful in diagnosing
people who have clear-cut severe
psychiatric disorders and we have
forgotten the importance of taking care
of them well there is no substitute for
DSM 4 or 5 I wish there was if there
could be a paradigm to a biological
model that was effective that would be
great that's what NIH wants but it's a
promise that can't be delivered Frank's
promise of a psychosocial model would be
very useful if it could be delivered but
right now we have nothing else we can't
forget the patients who have these
disorders now who are suffering
terrifically from them and who need help
and the fact of the matter is that we
have 1 million that's 1 million
psychiatric patients in prisons because
they're not receiving adequate care in
the community and a decent place to live
if they were diagnosed accurately and
treated effectively it would be a better
world so the attack shouldn't be is DSM
good or bad it should be how do we get a
mental health system that works because
that right now we don't have one so we
really need to put the DSM on a diet
right it's got to be slimmed down and
targeted and be more precise going
forward exactly right and we have to
stop the drug companies from having the
right to market we control the tobacco
industry which seemed all-powerful 20
years ago when we took away their right
to advertise if we prevented the drug
companies from advertising to consumers
if we stopped their marketing to doctors
the right patients would be getting
medication a lot of people are basically
well Alan I agree with that completely
that we're the only country in the world
that permits direct-to-consumer
advertising of medical medical products
and they had it in New Zealand and they
shut it down in 1998 but there's no
other country that does that and that is
partly responsible for the explosion and
prescription of easy to prescribe drugs
like selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors which are now prescribed more
for not depression something else
besides depression then then for
depression and that is and so I agree
about the drug companies having
shanghaied it and also I agree about the
prisons you know the prisons are now the
mental hospitals of the 19th century
they have they have replaced the mental
hospitals of the 19th century at 50% of
the people in correctional facilities or
aura or more have you'll have severe
mental illnesses or important mental
illnesses and because they're in prison
and not being treated and that's that's
an awful crime basically I would also
recommend the viewers read a new book
just out by a Goldacre I think I've got
his name right Alan
gold Laker in which he takes a look at
Big Pharma and how they conduct trials
of new drugs and his conclusion is that
many times negative results get buried
and so that's something that we have to
take seriously and look at closely when
it comes to medication for any of these
illnesses thank you I think the issue
here is very clear the psychiatric drugs
are very effective for the people who
really need them and psychiatry does as
well as other medical specialties if
it's limited to its proper competence
but if you take people with milder
problems that more often than not really
aren't psychiatric disorders the placebo
response rates over 50% and medication
is for the most part not helpful and
very often quite harmful and always
expensive I'm going to take a question
from Miriam W that was posted earlier
today since the DSM has I'm just going
to read this verbatim so there's not put
words in her mouth um since the DSM has
primarily become a tool for insurance
needs to decide what they will pay for
certain treatments what impact do you
think the recent changes for example of
Asperger's will have on patient services
you would like to check that one first
well I could say I think the services
will be restricted and it'll be harder
to get services and so that's an
educational and familial implication of
this particular change the DSM was never
created to determine school services
it's basically a clinical manual that
has only clinical purposes we need to
decouple the educational decisions from
a manual that really wasn't developed to
help make them the I support then I have
another question from Daisy spa - and
psychiatry began by describing abnormal
behavior it's in a very general way
without any knowledge of what might be
the origin of them the DSM still doesn't
seek cause but since then the tremendous
amount of knowledge has been amassed
about the cause of some behaviors
especially of children going up and
dysfunctional or abusive family
environments does the DSM need to be
rethought to include this new knowledge
well I can make it comment about that
you know the NIH yeah I think you have
had on the science um web the
information about the research the our
Doc's initiative at the NIH which is
seeking really to find the so-called
causes of mental disorders and when they
talk about the causes they talk about
biology and genetics and the brain but
actually the causes of mental disorder
that we know actually are social their
social causes so child sexual abuse is
one of the dominant prevent potentially
preventable causes of the entire range
of mental disorders and by focusing on
the brain and the biology and the
genetics
we're losing track of the possibility
that we can actually engage in
prevention activities so right now what
we know about mental disorders is that
the causes are mostly we can identify
them and they're in social form you know
that that fits into the biopsychosocial
cultural model which is an elusive model
for sure but one that I think we need to
pursue because you know the reductionist
approach by ni MH just simply will fail
and you know my and they're pushing hard
for lab based tests etc and I would like
to point out that people don't live in
labs they don't emote in labs that the
pain is not in the lab the living is not
in the lab and we do have to factor in
the cultural and social side as well as
the biological side in other words
nature and nurture are both involved in
this let me Alan I can talk more any
there he goes okay go ahead yeah I think
that the NIH made a terrible error in
over selling its ability to contribute
to a diagnostic system at this point the
the decade of the brain in the 1990s
revealed the tremendous amount of
fascinating neuroscience but yielded
nothing that was useful for clinical
science the brain is the most
complicated thing in the universe its
secrets are revealed only very very
slowly it will be a very long time
before we understand the causes of
mental illness on a biological basis we
meanwhile need to be treating patients
and we need to be doing that in a much
better way than we are doing it now I
think psychosocial models are absolutely
crucial to understanding mental illness
but we don't have at this point a
psychosocial model of diagnosis so
everyone talking about paradigm shifts
in the future DSM 5 said that the and
ima just talking about paradigm shifts
in the future
I think Frank is very eager to have a
paradigm shift for the future I think
that's all fine and good but we
shouldn't be taking our eye off the
current desperate needs of psychiatric
patients and these are not being met and
they could be met if only there were
adequate resources here here yeah so
let's talk about this from a patient's
perspective and the changes that you
talk about in your book Alan and that
you've mentioned Frank and and we've
alluded to William how should that
change the perspective of a patient or a
consumer of psychiatry somebody who
needs your help
sorry what's the question Emily so you
say it again the question is if there
needs to be a big shift and what do
patients make of this big transition
well they shouldn't be scared I mean it
is scary everything that you hear you
begin to think oh my gosh you know
psychiatrists are monsters and they
they're trying to foist this on
scientific thing on us
etc etc but there are very fine
practitioners in across the whole world
of the profession psychology psychiatry
Social Work etc who can help people and
I don't think that people who need help
should avoid getting help because they
become weary hearing all of this
criticism that's that's afoot and you
know if you've got problems go see a
professional and get started find a good
doctor that's the first rule you know
psychologists or psychiatrists find a
good doctor and there are good social
work people to treat as well yes there's
counselors a lot of good people out
there yeah I think the thing to be aware
of is that 80% of the medication
prescribed is prescribed by non
psychiatrists by primary care doctors
one in every five people in America is
taking a psychiatric drug we now have
more overdoses from prescription drugs
they're from street drugs there's a glut
of pill popping in our society and most
of it is being done by non psychiatrists
usually after very brief visits the
average is seven minutes with a stranger
who comes in on the worst day of his
life
and the drug salesman may have been in
the office just before convincing the
doctor that everyone has a psychiatric
disorder as a consumer be very well
informed a diagnosis is as important to
purchase in a way as a car or a house it
has to fit right you should know more
about diagnosis than you do about the
house that you've on you should never
accept the diagnosis after seven minutes
with a doctor never start taking a free
sample we are under treating people who
need it but most people go to a primary
care doctor and get a medication will
get better on their own the placebo
response rate is enormous people are
resilient life changes people get better
I think if you're a consumer for
yourself and especially for your kids be
aware of the fact that there's over
diagnosis and and frequent overuse of
medications and be very careful before
you accept medications for the problem
on the other hand if you have a severe
problem you're probably being under
treated but people with severe problems
are not getting enough help Allen I
agree the thing is the problem there is
a little bit the DSM but not really it's
the direct to consumer advertising
that's that's the number that's the
worst problem we have that's a little
bit off the subject Emily but that's
that's the problem that this country has
right now and is something we should
solve is not just not let drug companies
advertise drugs on TV because then a
person sees that they feel a little pain
or they feel a little sad they go to the
doctor and say I want some prozac and
what does the doctor gonna do he could
say no you can't have it if he says no
you can't have it he's got to spend
another 45 minutes or an hour or getting
a consultation to figure out what you
should be getting instead he says fine
he's got other patients to go here's the
pill so that's the anyway Emily I'd like
to add something to that as well it
might be slightly off target but maybe
not which is that the the evidence is
there's a critical mass of evidence
indicating that psychotherapy
works and this has really been achieved
mostly in about the last decade it's
based upon large-scale meta analyses of
controlled trials etc etc and so drugs
are not the only method of choice the
only treatment of choice
talk therapy works by and large and an
interesting finding is that the
particular method of therapy doesn't
really matter all that much whether it's
you know psychoanalysis dynamic approach
or cognitive behavioral approach etc
doesn't matter so much as we used to
think in other words the the method
variants the method effects are not as
as strong as we once thought and in fact
one of the key ingredients is the
interaction between the client and the
therapist and so psychotherapy works
your viewers may want to check out the
journal called psychotherapy this year
it had in 2013 a key article entitled
recognition of psychotherapy
effectiveness and that was in the
journal called psycho therapy this was a
publication this article is a
publication of the American
Psychological Association that
summarizes the literature to show the
effectiveness of psychotherapy can I
just second that I don't want to make
the point in the department of mental
health we have a global health unit and
interpersonal therapy psychotherapy
cognitive behavioral therapies trauma
focused behavioral therapies they
actually can be adapted effectively and
efficiently quickly to situations in
low-income countries around the world to
victims of tsunami for example victims
of genocide victims of rape and so forth
and they are terribly effective they're
even more effective than here in a way
because they've never been trying to
people all of a sudden sense that they
can actually recover that they can get
better and so that that's in a way a
little bit of the wave of the future and
it's it's not a it's not a it's not a
pill it's you can you can teach local
people with a high school education and
a relatively short time to to
to give a therapy which is effective and
that's the only way to have an effect in
that low-income countries right now let
me third that that the problem here is
that the a utaki Beller now go ahead o
the project I guess we have a little egg
the problem here is that the drug
companies have tens of billions of
dollars to advertise their wares
there's no advertisement for
psychotherapy there's no budget to push
psychotherapy the way there's a huge
budget to push pills
I think the insurance companies are also
to blame that they take a very short
term view of what's more expensive this
year worried that they won't have that
client for the longer haul psychotherapy
is just as effective perhaps more
effective fewer side-effects for mild to
moderate problems it doesn't work well
alone for severe problems but for mild
to moderate problems it's a much better
treatment insurance companies worry
about the short term costs which are
slightly higher for psychotherapy and
miss the fact looks like the therapy
lasts whereas drugs have to be taken for
often for a lifetime so I think if we
had a fair market evaluation of
psychotherapy compared to pills there'd
be a lot more psychotherapy in this
country a lot less pill popping okay
wouldn't it be wonderful I mean if if
psychiatry got back to doing more
cycling there and more talk therapy you
know it's become so much of a discipline
of the field to spend dispensing you
know and it wouldn't be great if they
got back a little bit more to to therapy
yeah they're aiming at a biological
target that probably doesn't exist in a
simple form or even in a very complex
form so on a slightly different tack um
the DSM is has been criticized for being
unscientific as it stands now um one
would hope it would become more
scientific how could that happen is what
the NIH is proposing is that the right
approach
well I I can make a comment about that I
think um people say and the NIH will say
listen we need to make we need to
validate the diagnosis we need to make
valid diagnosis and the use of the term
valid for diagnosis is not quite
appropriate validity is for measures not
for diagnosis so we have the physical
model we're looking for gallium for a
general audience can you explain what
that term means in this context so
validity is the degree to it we have a
measure and like a questionnaire or a
way of talking to somebody or a
biological marker and let's say a
cytokine in the blood you know a
chemical in the blood and the question
is when we take that chemical in the
blood if we do so for a disease like
cholera we look for evidence of the
cholera bacterium in the blood or
antibodies to it and that seems to imply
validity for that measure we don't have
that kind of validity for you for
psychiatry and it's possible we never
will we have to decide what is the most
efficient way to categorize our
perceptions what is the best way to and
so inevitably I think the DSM and in
future evolutions of it will be a
consensus document we have to decide
what's the most efficient and fair and
economical and useful way to categorize
disorders and it seems to me it's
unlikely to be in the next decades
something coming out of a brain measure
it's going to be something we get by
talking to somebody and trying to figure
out their problems in trying to and and
try to help each individual not
necessarily a biomarker they're
searching for biomarkers that's a
phantom I think probably for most
psychiatric problems you know we've been
searching for biomarkers for a long time
Emily and haven't haven't found any I
guess my concern is that again the
Jonah's biomedical model is is not the
way to go
you know it's got to be across the whole
experience therefore again the
biopsychosocial cultural model bringing
nate inert nature in with nurture and
trying to figure this thing out in terms
of the current dsm-5 I mean the the
measurement data were poor I mean the
the agreement among judges the so-called
CAPA score which is a statistic I mean
some of them were abysmal some we're
okay you know none of them are great but
for example I'm just taking a look
um I think explaining the Capitol Square
would be useful well is simply a
statistic to show how much let's say to
diagnosticians agree when they do an
independent diagnosis I mean that's the
simplest way of describing it and so it
boils it down to a number so point zero
zero would be terrible no agreement
whatsoever point nine nine would be a
fabulously high agreement I mean perfect
agreement between these two independent
judges well if you take a look at some
of the disorders in the dsm-5 my gosh
they were dreadful mixed anxiety
depression disorder obsessive-compulsive
personality antisocial personality
disorder some of them had negligibly
kappa scores in other words no
reliability so my concern would be that
they shouldn't fly these things until
they've got really good reliability you
know one of the key ingredients of
science is replication replication
replication and in this case they didn't
replicate these things you know they
didn't they should have replicated these
reliability figures over and over again
until they got good reliability before
they forced it onto the American people
so that's my view and going forward
that's something that has to really
build be dealt with Frank I call them
you do s you do s unidentified
diagnostic objects
and they're funny you know mixed anxiety
the person disorder is it unidentified
diagnostic object but I have to say you
know my background is sociology so I
started a long time ago 25 years ago
very skeptical of the DSM and the
diagnostic process and I took
epidemiologic data and tried to figure
out how it would statistical cluster in
the population and with a completely
exploratory empirical method and we
develop we developed we found three
clusters a normal cluster and people who
had lots of different symptoms but not
sadness and then the third cluster I
thought I had literally shot over the
horizon and hit the press of disorder so
and I thought oh my gosh how can that be
so and then in later research I've
discovered that depressive disorder
predicts two things like stroke and
diabetes heart attack and dementia and
it's not depressive syndrome or
dysphoria or suicidal ideation or it's
the depressive disorder itself that does
that pretty cannot panic not alcohol
depressive disorder so some of the
diagnoses are good and some of them are
you do s
and and and the problem is that the DSM
doesn't really let us sort through which
ones are useful in which not every
practitioner has to do that for
themselves if I could just pick up on a
couple of points and make some
contextual remarks I think it's easy to
criticize where psychiatry is but we
have to put the context in that most of
medicine has similar problems the
translation from basic science to
clinical science has been very very
difficult for all of medicine the we've
been fighting the war against cancer for
forty years losing most of the battles
we learned about a gene that help
predict breast cancer 20 years ago but
we still don't understand what causes
most of breast cancer it's a very slow
slog to understand
many illness and if it's hard to
understand breast cancer with an organ
that's so much simpler than the brain
imagine how difficult it will be to
understand schizophrenia so we shouldn't
have a standard that makes it sound like
the rest of Medicine has solved it's
translational problems and psychiatry is
the only unique situation we're lagging
so far behind it's a general problem
we've done a lot more for cancer by
stopping smoking than by all the
biological research that's been done at
NIH I think we have to look at all of
our disorders in a more public health
perspective dsm-5 is absolutely useless
I recommend that no one buy it that no
one uses it that no one teach it that
doesn't mean that the sm4 is special we
could probably do well to go back to the
sm-3 but we do have to have some common
knowledge some common knowledge and some
common language for discourse and I
think that if we stick to the disorders
that are well described
if we focus as bill suggests in that and
I think Frank also on schizophrenia and
bipolar disorder on severe depressions
not the mild ones on severe
obsessive-compulsive disorder severe
panic disorder and we could list about
15 more when these disorders present in
their severe form they're absolutely
characteristic reliabilities no problem
and treatment guidelines are very very
clear-cut psychiatry and the mental
health professions in general get into
trouble when they go into the shades of
gray areas that are on the fuzzy and
very populous boundary with normality
and at that point we over diagnosed an
over treat and if we spend all our
resources on people who don't need it we
don't have resources left for the people
who really do and also I agree about if
we if we focus sorry Frank if we if we
focus on genetics for example you gave
the breast cancer gene but there's a
gene we know the gene for Huntington's
chorea we've known that for decades and
it really has not helped anything and we
have that you know in the NIH our Doc's
they they want to merge together studies
of schizophrenia and bipolar disorder
because the genes overlap but and it's
true that the genes overlap but the
genes are not going to help us that much
I think it turns out that the
epidemiologic data on
schizophrenia and depression and bipolar
disorder are very distinct so you have
for us tickets afrien iya you have a
raft of risk factors you have urban
isset e for example use of drugs age of
the Father there's a list of different
risk factors for schizophrenia not that
we understand why they work but they're
they're they're replicated risk factors
and basically bipolar disorder is a
blank page so they're very different in
epidemiologic terms and in the Natural
History and merging them together
because the genes overlap is an over
focus on genetics and biology that's
that's one thing you know on on the
issue of oh sorry Emily we're gonna take
another question okay okay I'm talking
too much
it's okay would you want me to uh oh
okay
well just returning briefly to the
benchmark diagnosis schizophrenia in the
dsm-5 the agreement between judges was
actually in the low moderate range so
even with this you know historically
sort of understood category into Freni
it the kappa scores of 0.46 which is
kind of low moderate and I'd like to
follow up on al Allen's comments about
all the problems that are you know not
just in psychiatry psychology etc but in
medicine in general your viewers might
want to take a look at some of the
recent radical criticism of general
medical science there's a fella by the
name of yo Nate you need us a professor
at Stanford University who wrote an
article in the Journal of the American
Medical Association
what above 2007 I as I recall and your
viewers can look it up but his argument
is that somewhere between 40 and 45
percent of all medical findings are
false
obviously that's got to be dealt with
and I think there are serious problems
in in science these days failures to
replicate you know in the world of
psychiatry and psychology I hate to say
it but we typically don't replicate
studies direct replications over
generalizations
emphasizing laboratory studies in in
behavior and ignoring where behavior
really takes place the important
behaviors don't take place in
laboratories as I mentioned earlier so I
think there's some general issues in
contemporary science that need to be
looked into Thanks
so this is a question from a mall do you
think the brain initiative announced by
President Obama is going to bring new
hope to the horizon in innovating new
tools and guidelines for psychiatric and
mental illness I think we've covered a
lot of background but it's worth
mentioning well I think it's gonna be a
very slow slog there will be no homeruns
there'll be no walks there'll be lots of
strikeouts and occasional singles the
the brain being as complicated and as
elusive as it is the secrets do not come
out in we don't have a Newton or an
Einstein or a Darwin in medicine not
just like I treat medicine and we never
will that these are small batches of
knowledge I think we should not be so
distracted by future for over-promising
that we ignore current need and people
should take with a grain of salt the new
finding each day that seems to be curing
cancer or giving the secret to
schizophrenia because it always turns
out to be oversold medicine travels in
very small steps I think it's like
exploring the universe the brain is is
in each human brain is infinite
basically it's it's in essence infinite
and it's the most complex as Alan said
it's the most complex thing on the
planet each brain and so it's but on the
other hand it's worth exploring I'm all
in favor of it's just as Alan is saying
it's gonna be like exploring the
universe it's going to take us a long
time and it's very big and very
complicated and the studies tend to be
very small laboratory based for example
the functional MRI is the device of
choice these days in neuroscience we're
attempting to connect brain
process with and it's an extremely
artificial unusual situation for testing
and the if you look closely at the
studies they tend to be very small
studies under extremely constrained
conditions and unfortunately often the
authors of these studies over generalize
dramatically to the way things are
outside the laboratory in the real world
and that's a problem
they we we have a kind of monastic
science these days due to it partly the
functional MRI and all of these brain
imaging techniques that sort of keep us
in the laboratory and from here we make
in the laboratory to make dramatic
generalizations and that you know that
that trend Alan mentioned earlier
translational science as I recall you
know it's still a big step in a big
problem yes bill mentioned brilliantly
it's like exploring the universe there
are just as many neurons in each of our
little three-pound brains as there are
stars in the entire galaxy each of those
neurons there's a thousand connections
to other neurons and each of these is
firing a thousand times a second and
there are hundreds of different
chemicals and proteins that are
mediating what happens it's a miracle
our brains work at all we should be very
grateful that evolution created this
remarkable machine we shouldn't be
surprised at the difficulty of teasing
out the secrets there won't be one
schizophrenia there'll be hundreds maybe
thousands of causes of schizophrenia
races there won't be one breast cancer
there may be a hundred different causes
of breast cancer this is a slow slog but
the the good news is we have good
treatments now they're not perfect the
diagnostic system is imperfect but if we
direct it the right way would provide
resources where they really belong we
have very good results we can get people
better we just need to get the
treatments to the right people
and psychotherapy is working again yep
no but you know an advantage of the
diagnostic system which I think Alan
alluded to maybe is that you can
communicate between practitioners a
little bit but another advantage is you
can make us
assessments of the way the mental health
system is working so you made the
statement Alan before that I think that
so many of you 50 percent of the people
in correctional facilities have a mental
disorder that sort of statement that
would be hard to make without a
diagnostic system of some kind in place
and you can make a statement that a
given healthcare system is taking better
or worse care of a given population you
need really a diagnostic system in order
to do that and we're not actually doing
it very well now and I don't know if the
sm5 will help us do that but we needed
some kind of diagnostic system in order
to make assessments of the mental health
system itself I think that's a nice
segue to a question from dr. Amy price
she asks why not combine biology and
psychology with all giving input
combining markers for prevention
biomarkers and hopefully spending less
early for a better value and quality of
life it's a bit pregnant is it too late
to do anything but damage damage control
later on for severe illness that's a lot
of questions together but take any piece
of that you will what if I could respond
briefly Emily to this I'm co-chair of a
committee that's looking forward that's
looking towards growth looking towards
new thinking and fresh thinking or
diagnosis is concern and we have a
website that just went live in the last
10 days two weeks and it's d-x summit so
any way of getting that up on the screen
DX summit dot org D X summit s um MIT
org and it's a place platform for
discussion of all of these things we're
looking at at going beyond the
biomedical model and and again the the
biopsychosocial cultural model if you
will and seeing if sorry Frank you've
said that several times and I was hoping
you could explain what that is well what
I mean by it is is is bringing in
evidence from across the the realm of
human behavior not just the brain but
culture you
relationships family society social
behavior etc you know people's pain and
distress isn't just brain you know it
connected it's connected with
relationships with your culture with
society with peers with family etc etc
and so we want to pull all those
together and move on from where
diagnosis is right now and and so this
this website your caller or your viewer
might want to go to this website we're
inviting people to participate to join
in in a global discussion going forward
and seeing if we can begin to evolve
some new conceptions of diagnosis as an
alternative to the extremely criticized
system that we have now that's actually
an also a nice opening to a question
from Steve Watkins that was Bob
yesterday um he wrote a long paragraph
so I'm just gonna pull one question out
um how do you define normal behavior
when you're looking across cultures um
can you can you speak to that please I
think Alan should take off on that he's
got a whole book called saving normal
which is the greatest title of the year
yeah well several thoughts I think that
every definition of normal winds up
being tautological there are a lot of
commonplace words in our lives that we
think we understand and we really don't
so when you get right down to it most
definitions of normal wind up being
something like that which is not
abnormal most definitions of abnormal
will get to be that which is not normal
and obviously in different cultures and
different times these are social
constructs that's vary dramatically
depending on the needs of the moment we
shouldn't think of the DSM definitions
as being diseases these are constructs
that are current most useful way of
looking at things if they're used
carefully and if they're written with
restraint I think that the previous
collimator a very important point is
there a preventive psychiatry can we
help to keep people normal
to prevent them from being sick
identifying before they get sick the the
tell-tale signs and treating them
expectantly to prevent it and wouldn't
this be wonderful if we could prevent
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder or
serious depressions the real sad point
to make is that we don't have the tools
to accurately identify who will later go
on to have problems and in medicine in
general preventive screening has for the
most part turned out to be more harmful
than helpful and all the medical
specialties are pulling back a great
deal I think if you're a parent protect
your kids from anyone who says that they
have an ability to prevent future
illness that the harms of treating
people expectantly turn out to be much
worse than the probable problems they'll
have in the future we have to be very
cautious Hippocrates said do no harm we
should do what we do well more than
we're doing it and we should avoid
adventures into the unknown until
they've been established with very very
solid evidence but Emily it's very good
oh go ahead bill well I was going to say
I agree with that 99.9 percent which let
me just take off the other point one
percent it's true that's good we don't
have good ways of screening and then
preventing but we do have Universal
Prevention's so and those actually are
effective so we can take and week we've
done this at Johns Hopkins we can take a
classroom based intervention teach teach
trained a teacher a different way of
teaching and or we can train parents
about child sexual abuse to to protect
their children from it it's not that
hard it's it's not selective it's
universal and those intervention now
they will have effect 15 20 25 years
down the road the classroom based
intervention for example lowers a rate
of risky sex lowers the rate of
antisocial personality disorder makes it
much less likely the people will smoke
tobacco or take drugs so that those are
they bit but the thing is they're
complex and
they're social interventions and they
aren't selective they're universal
we can have an effect by protecting
children from abuse yeah that'll big
effect we don't do it that's perfect I
think that if we want to prevent
attention deficit disorder
we shouldn't be identifying kids at risk
for it we should be improving the
schools now if we want to reduce the
risk of PTSD maybe we shouldn't be
getting our soldiers involved in so many
horrible Wars
but we should also be improving their
transition back to the civilian economy
if we want to reduce depression after
unemployment we should be training
people for new jobs rather than trying
to identify the individual person job so
if we if we identify societal problems
and try to prevent them that's great but
what I am against is trying the the
effort which I think it's futile at this
point of identifying the individual
who's the specific individual who's
likely to go on to have those problems
and attempting to treat him let's treat
the social context not so much the
supposed individual at risk Emily I'd
like to add about defining normal I mean
that is a problem we're talking about
abnormal when we're talking about DSM
etc but do we have a good purchase on
what normality is and the answer is no
we don't so for example you take
adolescent behavior that alleged
risk-taking etc and sense of
invulnerability and all the risky
behaviors of adolescents there's
approximately 100 cultures in which you
don't even see that and so that's a
cross-cultural example of how you define
normal and that's so important for
diagnosis you know we have we don't want
to pathologize simply extremes of
behavior you know unless they are
totally interfering with life etc etc I
study extreme behavior all over the
world of different different kinds of
extreme behavior and you know people are
doing fabulous things and and perhaps
under the DSM they might be diagnosed
with something but they're not they're
not ill and so we need a better purchase
on what normality is well I was going to
say
just to give an example of
cross-cultural differences you know
folks and our global mental health
program have gone into different
cultures in Africa and they will go to a
local healer and they'll say what kind
of problems do you have here what to put
with and how are people when they get
upset what kind of thing is it and in
some cultures the local healer will say
something and name something and
basically list off that the cemetery
afford oppressive disorder and the
culture across the river or a hundred
miles away there will be nothing
resembling depressive disorder so it's
very culturally bound her go the reason
to get culture factored into this whole
system this is dr. Amy price again she
wants to know why not make better use of
combining population data to inform
imaging studies and ask the right
research question so that a real
diagnosis is possible and again getting
back to this question of how to do you
want me to repeat it you have it well
I'd like to answer it I'd respond
imaging studies won't you know they they
can help us out a certain amount but my
gosh there are no way to approach
diagnosis no they just you know for one
thing the studies are overwhelmingly
correlational and I mentioned earlier
they're based upon very small restricted
to the samples tested under extremely
artificial conditions and again people's
distress usually is out there in the
real world outside the monastery walls
and so we're not going to you know
they're helpful perhaps in driving some
theory and making more connections
between nature and nurture but we can we
can't place all the weight on imaging
studies and what imaging studies might
review so there's an interest think I
mean there's a research design issue and
just to bring up its a Kay occasionally
the imaging studies yield something
that's very interesting for example the
size of the hippocampus as being related
to exposure to combat or post-traumatic
stress and but it's just so rare that
something like that comes up and it's
not diagnostically useful on the other
hand the imaging studies that are done
would benefit a great deal by combining
with a population base so if they do
imaging Studies on people already in
treatment that is a very distinct
population they really have to try to
generalize the imaging studies to the
whole population not just the treated
population the treated population tends
to have more than one disorder for
example and they tend to have different
orientations toward recovery and so
forth do you have a socially yeah
Tolstoy said that all happy families are
happy in the same way every unhappy
family is unhappy in its own particular
way meaning you had to get lots of
things right to be happy and lots of
things could go wrong to make you
unhappy it's like that with mental
disorders there will be a hundred or
thousand different pathways to
schizophrenia we're not going to
discover these in any way it's not going
to be a understanding of this cause
schizophrenia there'll be many many
different pathways just as there will be
for breast cancer so I don't think that
there's going to be a sudden
breakthrough and it's not that the
people doing the research are dumb
they're as smart as can be the problem
is that the research is very very
difficult and it's going to take decades
and that's why we can't over promise it
yeah well since you bring up Tolstoy and
families I'm gonna go to another
question from Thomas Mason who can speak
this is a rich topic who can speak about
family neuroses passed down through the
generations familial genetic disorders
anybody interested well I think that one
of the misconceptions is that if you
have a family member who has a
psychiatric disorder you're going to get
one the genetics have been so emphasized
so over emphasized that people feel
there's a kind of fatalism about being
in a family where other people have had
mental problems it's a risk factor it's
an important risk factor but it
increases your risk only so much and
most people who have a relative who
schizophrenic or bipolar disorder ninety
percent of them are not going to have
that problem themselves I think it's
important for people not to be over
emphasizing the biological facts missing
all the other things that go into who
gets sick and who doesn't including just
simple bad luck so are you suggesting
Alan there might be some slight
confirmation bias in in this you you
believe you're gonna get it and you get
it yeah science has been terrifically
oversold in order to get into a journal
you have to exaggerate the meaning of
your result you often do so many
analyses that the ones you report are
only a very tiny fraction of all the
negative results
the journals don't have readers if they
don't have positive results they send
out news releases that make it look like
each paper is going to solve that
disease that week this is a very slow
process of retail process and it's
important that people not be so dazzled
by the science that they worry more than
they need to about themselves or that
they imagine that there'll be quick
solutions to problems the more were
distracted about the future promise the
less we deliver on current need so it's
it's not years
it's decades and scores and hundreds of
years basically that we have to
investigate the brain and figure out how
it relates to the entire range of
emotional problems
it's a would exciting adventure this is
one of the intellectual triumphs in the
history of mankind has been the last 30
years of studying how the brain works
it's terrifically exciting but it's not
going to translate it to better pay
here in the very near future but in a
sense one positive outcome perhaps a
dsm-5 is to generate the kind of
discussions we're having to you know to
force my hard thinking about causality
and and the quality of science and its
applications etc so there might be you
know silver lining here I see another
possible silver lining I think that we
should take this opportunity this crisis
of confidence in psychiatry and and
begin a congressional investigation of
how psychiatric diagnosis should be done
a congressional investigation of drug
company marketing the insurance industry
is rewarding its incentives are not
aligned with best patient care there are
many things that good things good
consequences sometimes happen from very
bad mistakes and my hope is that the
various discussions franks and others
that are now being entered into will
have a payoff in better patient care
perhaps the self-correcting factor in
science may help you know when i took a
look at those kappa scores you know the
agreement scores between professionals
judging the using the diagnostic
categories and how low some of these
agreements were in you know in
diagnosing using the dsm-5 system i was
shocked and i thought to myself now
there's where the corrective strength of
science needs to come to play you know
to approach though the that basic
reliability issue in diagnosis and try
to figure out how those diagnoses can be
improved to raise the reliability
coefficient let me make a comment about
that that the reliability is not
something that in here's in the
diagnosis it depends very much on how
its tested and the dsm field trials were
just in competently designed and in
competently done the results were
impossible to interpret because some
things were like major depressive
disorder you can get good reliability
they didn't it's not because it's
impossible to do it's the way they did
it
the diagnostic system is in
it's reliability it is certainly not
what we'd like it to be but it's
reliable enough for the severe diagnosis
to guide treatment in a good way people
should not lose faith in the whole
system because dsm-5 wasn't done well
and if I can just make a historical
comment there were reviews of
psychiatric diagnosis before the third
edition and in 1980 in the 70s and they
basically showed it wasn't just a point
for the Kappas were zero they were zero
in point one and point two they were
useless
the diagnostic of ability in before
night before the third revision was
pretty much useless and so the DSM 3 at
least had that effect it did change the
reliability the degree to which you
could make reliable diagnosis however
schizophrenia as again the benchmark
diagnosis was much better in DSM for
much better
we've got three minutes so three um
we're gonna wrap up pretty soon if
anybody would like to make a final
comment um please go ahead and then we
will say our goodbyes
unfortunately it's way too funny well I
would hope that people would be
optimistic look to the future think
about ways we can improve this situation
I've mentioned our new website where
that's exactly the attitude that we have
to broaden our discussion about
diagnosis and hopefully come up with a
better blueprint going forward and all
of your viewers are invited to compile
on this website DX summit dot org you
know there's also a dsm-5 MOOC website
that started I think that there's a lot
of excitement now about improving the
future that's a good result of this
terrible present but if you're a patient
be informed get help if you need it
avoid it if you don't my only you know
final comment would be - from the point
of view of Public Health we have to try
to figure out how the diagnostic system
and the Prevention's and treatments we
know improves the health of the entire
population it's true we concentrated an
individual
but we have to keep in mind the entire
population that that's the public health
approach that you know I'm invested in
um so thank you so much for joining us
today this has been great and wonderful
so for our viewers this chats going to
be archived on the website if you want
to see it later
next week's chat on May 30th is going to
be about the future of chimps and
research um that's all for today thank
you so much for joining us
okay thanks are you doing nice to be
with you guys - thanks Emily thanks Alan
it Frank nice to me